Elma vielleicht die erste Frage an dich
aus aktuellem Anlass in acht Tagen
glaube ich aber jetzt vier Flugobjekte
vom Himmel geholt was weiß man denn
inzwischen darüber man hört so wenig am
meisten weiß man über den ersten der
vier den wir da auch sehen das ist ein
ganz offenbar spionageballon sagen die
Amerikaner weil an dem hing dran
Kommunikationsausrüstung das heißt
Kameras das heißt Mikrofone mit denen
man auch Kommunikation Abhören
überwachen kann das wissen wir bisher
schon und er ist abgeschossen worden
eben vor der Küste von South Carolina
jetzt sammelt man die Trümmer die
anderen drei die danach noch
abgeschossen wurden fallen
möglicherweise eine ganz andere
Kategorie nämlich harmlos
vergleichsweise harmlos Wetter
man geht jetzt davon aus dass es
vielleicht recht harmlose Objekte waren
tatsächlich Balance vielleicht sogar ein
privater Ballon wo Studenten einen
Experiment gemacht haben aber das ist
nicht ungewöhnlich weil pro Jahr schickt
alleine amerikanische Wetterdienst 60
auf 1000 solcher Balance in die Luft und
momentan ist man natürlich sehr ich sag
mal aufgeregt und deswegen wird alles
abgeschossen was da über den Himmel aber
wir sind so hysterisch mittlerweile dass
wir nicht mal mehr ein Wetterballon von
einem spionageballon deutlich
unterscheiden können ich glaube der
Druck ist unglaublich hoch auf die
beiden Administration wir haben das ja
erlebt Abgeordnete beider Partei die im
Grunde sagen es kann doch nicht sein
dass dieser eine Balance es geschafft
hat einmal quer über die USA drüber zu
fliegen bis man ihn dann abgeschossen
hat und jetzt wird so früh wie möglich
alles abgeschossen weil man nicht 100%
sicher ist ob es nicht doch auch
Spionage gewesen es heißt auch das kam
auch ganz früh das zu Zeiten von Trump
gab es angeblich drei solcher Vorfälle
ja drei Ballons keine abgeschossen ja
warum nicht es schwer zu sagen im
Nachhinein die
Regierung von Trump oder
Regierungsmitglieder behaupten sie
hätten nie davon erfahren der
Verteidigungsminister der nationale
Sicherheitsberater sie hätten nie davon
erfahren dass das gewesen sei ein Ballon
gegenüber Florida einer über Texas einer
über Guam aber offenbar nur ganz kurz
und die beiden Administrationen
behauptet damals war niemandem wirklich
aufgegangen um was es sich handelte und
man habe selber tatsächlich seit dem 20
Februar
diesen einen Ballon Entschuldigung seit
dem 20 Januar diesen einen Ballon
getrackt der von der Insel heinan
aufgestiegen ist in China und hat ihn
also über Tage verfolgt bis er dann in
den amerikanischen Luftraum über Alaska
eingedrungen ist und weiter verfolgt und
offenbar erst dann angefangen
Geheimdienstes Erkenntnisse der letzten
Jahre einfach mal zusammenzuziehen und
kam zu dem Schluss da ist ein großes
Programm
aber nicht ganz verstanden worum es sich
handelt warum diese Ballons fragt man
sich
Ärger ist oder könnt ihr das Lösen also
das wirkt ja so furchtbar Retro ja
zeigten von Satelliten Google oder
Alphabet können in jedem Winkel dieses
Planeten gucken warum Balance na gut ich
meine cheating Ping ist ein absoluter
kontrollfuzi das wissen die Chinesen
seit Jahren er hat die Zahl der
Überwachungskameras in seiner Amtszeit
von 100 Millionen auf 600 Millionen
erhöht also es gibt auf zwei Chinesen
gibt es eine Überwachungskamera die die
Hälfte aller Überwachungskamera auf
Erden sind in China montiert genau und
diese Kontrolle da er weltweite
Ansprüche hat weltweit eine
Vorherrschaft möchte darum möchte er
diese Kontrolle weltweit ausdehnen und
da bieten sich neben den Satelliten die
natürlich auch gibt diese Ballons an
weil die langsamer sind das heißt Sie
können länger auch an einer Stelle
bleiben und die sind auch besser
geeignet um Kommunikation Mikrofon das
Thema spannend wie ist denn das Ereignis
in China aufgenommen worden wissen sie
das na gut berichtet
gehört hat was das Außenministerium
sagte die USA hätten überreagiert im
chinesischen Internet ist es eher so mit
mit Ironie aufgenommen worden Chinesen
kennt sogar Nena 99 Luftballons auch das
wurde in dem Zusammenhang erwähnt also
ich meine man muss erstmal ehrlich sagen
es ist ja also es gibt keinen Grund zum
moralisieren ich meine die die Amis
haben haben das Handy von Angela Merkel
abgehört also äh es ist ja nicht der
Punkt an sich das alle spioniert genau
der Punkt ist halt wirklich dass China
sich in früheren Jahrzehnten sehr stark
zurückgehalten hat sich nur auf die
innere Entwicklung konzentriert hat
während möchte vorher schafft über die
ganze Welt und haben natürlich auch
spionieren in der ganzen Angela Merkel
erwähnt haben
Christoph Häuschen war neulich hier
langjährige außenpolitischer Berater der
der sagte das sind alarmierendes
Ereignis und wir leben in diesem
Konflikt Russland Ukraine aber
eigentlich geht es um ein ganz anderen
Konflikt den Konflikt dahinter nämlich
die Rivalität zwischen den USA und China
und sie sagen Herr Geiges es ist
auffällig wie es bei dem Thema letzter
Zeit dann Intensität zugenommen hat
obwohl
also man sieht eigentlich
zwei Sachen parallel man sieht hier in
Europa hier reden über Panzerlieferungen
für den Krieg in der Ukraine und bei
diesem Konflikt zwischen China und den
USA geht es um künstliche Intelligenz
das ist das was für diesen Krieg
entscheidend ist und auch bei diesen
Ballons jetzt da gab es offenbar das
wissen sie besser in den USA vom
US-Militär auch so eine Übung für die
über die Datenverbindungen und das ist
der große Wettlauf im Moment zwischen
den USA und China künstliche Intelligenz
und im Moment sieht vieles danach aus
also China da
die Nase vorn hätte zumindest ist das
das was chiching Ping anstrebt und was
seine Leute dazu verdonnert das zu
erreichen die Amerikaner nehmen das
offenbar sehr sehr ernst der
Außenminister hat gerade den Besuch in
China auch abgesagt und Elmar sagt auch
das was wir da in der Ukraine sehen das
Engagement der Amerikaner für die
Ukraine hat den Wahrheit ganz viel mit
Taiwan zu tun warum ich will das mal
anhand von einer Anekdote klar machen
wir waren vor fast einem Jahr im März
letzten Jahres mit Joe beiden in
Warschau im Schloss hat er ja seine
große Rede gehalten Ende März letzten
Jahres am Vorabend hatte man uns gebeten
in einen Raum zu kommen das gäbe ein
Hintergrundgespräch stehe Konvent mit
Administration officials und wir waren
fest davon ausgegangen das sind dann
Pressesprecher vom weißen Haus von
Ministerien es kamen aber dann die Tür
ging auf tatsächlich
Ängste Kabinetts Mitglieder der
US-Regierung herein Ängste Berater von
Joe Weiden und die standen dann uns zur
Verfügung um ihn Fragen zu stellen auch
im eins zu eins Gespräch und ich habe
gefragt das was man da gerade mit
Russland macht wäre man dazu auch bereit
wegen Taiwan mit China zu machen also
Wirtschaftssanktionen militärische
Unterstützung und so weiter und die
Antwort war von beiden sehr klar ja
anders als im Ukraine Konflikt würden
die USA direkt militärisch auch
eingreifen wenn China Taiwan angreift
und deswegen ist der Ukraine Krieg so
wichtig er zeigt im Grunde genommen wenn
man Putin damit davon kommen lässt dass
er ein Land einfach besetzt erobert zum
Teil russischen Territoriums erklärt
dann könnte China daraus den Schluss
ziehen es wäre auch in der Lage und der
Westen wäre zu schwach um das zu
verhindern er könnte Taiwan erobern und
das steht hinter diesem Engagement der
Amerikaner zum großen Teil natürlich
spielt auch eine Rolle man braucht ein
stabiles Europa und da kann man keinen
russischen Anführer gebrauchen der
anfängt die umliegenden Länder
gewissermaßen zu erobern
wissen die Chinesen dass Herr Geige ist
denen das klar
sozusagen warum die Amerikaner sich da
so engagieren was wie wichtig diese
taiwanfrage ist warum ist Taiwan so
wichtig für dich Chinesen
also taiwan ist für die Chinesen wichtig
weil das ja ein wichtiger Bestandteil
dieser nationalistischen Rhetorik ist
das ist Teil unseres Mutterlandes und
wir müssen uns mit denen Vereinen und
das ist jetzt aber so interessant
geworden das war in den Zeiten
vorschieben war das so eine festtagsrede
so wie wir so in den äh 70er und 80er
Jahren deutsche Einheit hat keiner dran
geglaubt so und cheating Ping suggeriert
dass er zu sein Leben und Amtszeiten
Taiwan heim ins Reich holen wird und das
macht die Sache so gefährlich weil er
sich damit unter Zeitdruck gesetzt hat
andere wichtiger Grund ist 64 Prozent
der Halbleiter der Computerchips
weltweit werden in Taiwan hergestellt
deshalb muss man sagen so schlimm das
ist was in der Ukraine passiert aber für
die Welt geht es in Taiwan noch um viel
mehr nämlich da geht es um die
Herrschaft über die Welt wer diese
Computerchips hat hat kann alle anderen
Länder Untersetzung diese wirklich
leistungsfähigen Rechner geht wenn es um
Tier SMC heißt die Firma und die ist
diese diese Computerfirma das heißt auch
dieser diese sehr aggressive
Herangehensweise was die Amerikaner da
gemacht haben mit den Chinesen sagen wir
es geht nicht um die einfachen
Halbleiter ne die in vielen Autos
teilweise 1000 Stück verbaut sind das
können die Chinesen längst selber und
das machen ja auch erfolgreich wenn es
darum geht eine Scheibe auf und zu
machen oder eher wächst auszulösen aber
es geht um diese
Hochleistungsprozessoren die dann
künstliche Intelligenz gigantische
Datenmengen und so weiter auslesen
musste erkennen können und so weiter
also die Technologie von morgen
und dann gehen die einfach hin und sagen
kriegt ihr nicht mehr genau weil man
radikal das hatten einfachen Grund vor
einigen Jahren haben die USA erkannt
dass amerikanische Technologie
Softwaretechnologie und auch Hardware in
am chinesischen Raketen steckt
okay offenbar war ich so dass eine Firma
namens phythium eine chinesische Firma
Hochleistungsprozessoren gefertigt hat
die in den neuen überschallraketen der
Chinesen verbaut worden sind hey das ist
der Westen hat den Chinesen ohne es zu
wollen aber geholfen dieser Raketen weil
in diesen Chips von physiom übrigens
gefertigt in Taiwan steckt Technologie
von zwei amerikanischen Firmen aus
Kalifornien und das haben die Amerikaner
durch Spionage durch Aufklärung
herausbekommen und als einen Belohnung
vielleicht könnte sein oder vielleicht
mit menschlichen Quellen jedenfalls das
Ergebnis ist es wurde klar dass China
aufrüsteten Massivs auch mit
verlässlicher Technologie und eben mit
einer Halbleitertechnologie die wir in
Europa und in den USA teilweise führend
bei einigen Firmen haben es gibt ein
kleines niederländisches Unternehmen als
ml heißt das ASML genau das war so klein
sind die nicht das stellt quasi
Werkzeuge her um diese winzigen
Halbleiter herzustellen und zu verbauen
und der Premierminister der Niederlande
war vor zwei Wochen in Washington und
hat mit Joe Biden darüber hinter
verschlossenen Türen beraten weil die
Amerikaner sicherstellen wollen dass
diese Fähigkeiten diese Werkzeuge die in
den Niederlanden hergestellt werden
nicht in die Hände Chinas geraten wenn
man fest überzeugt ist dass diese
Technologie in chinesischen Waffen
verbaut wird und dann natürlich genutzt
werden kann zum Beispiel um
amerikanische flugzeugträgergruppen
anzugreifen denn gerade diese Überschall
Raketen sind als aircraft carrier
bekannt das sind Raketen mit denen
tatsächlich komplette Flugzeugträger
ausgeschaltet werden können und übrigens
nicht nur in den chinesischen Waffen
sondern ist es ja jetzt herausgekommen
in der großen Geschichte des World
Channels dass die Chinesen ja jetzt
solche Halbleiter die auch dual use also
auch militärisch genutzt werden können
nach Russland die von zwei Mengen und
das ist nämlich auch zurück zur Frage
nach der chinesischen Haltung da also
wenn in der chinesischen Presse über den
Krieg in der Ukraine berichtet wird sind
da immer zwei Fotos auf der einen Seite
ist Putin und auf der anderen Seite ist
nicht silenski sondern Joe beiden das
heißt die chinesische Darstellung ist
das sei ein Krieg zwischen den USA und
Russland und da ist China ganz klar
Partei ist tatsächlich Parteien ja also
man bemüht sich ja wahnsinnig den
Eindruck zu erwecken wir haben mit
nichts was zu tun und wir wollen
eigentlich nur ein bisschen Handel
treiben und so weiter aber es gab sehr
interessant also der Krieg ist ja jetzt
quasi der Tag an dem sich das
traurigerweise jährt der 24 Februar aber
der vierte Februar aber auch interessant
dieses Treffen Putin und heating Ping wo
man sich unverbrüchliche Freundschaft
geschworen hat für immer und für alle
Zeiten und dann auf die Frage die eine
Sprecherin der chinesischen Regierung
die sagte auf die Frage könnte es sein
dass die die Ukraine angreifen
antwortete fand ich an ihren Satz was
glauben Sie denn was passiert wenn man
an so großes Land wie Russland so in die
Ecke drängt das heißt da gibt es ein
gemeinsames Verständnis von dem was da
passiert auf jeden Fall also es war ja
die Eröffnung der Olympischen
Winterspiele in pekingen aber auch
interessant Peking die einzige Stadt der
Welt diese sowohl Sommerspiele als auch
Winterspiele hatte und dann kommt er
ausländische Politiker unter anderem
Putin und normalerweise bei so einem
Sport Ereignis sind das ja so
Höflichkeit treffen und die haben aber
stattdessen eine gemeinsame Erklärung
verabschiedet die eigentlich darauf
hinausläuft die gegenwärtige Weltordnung
umzustürzen wo sie gemeinsam sagen die
Welt das muss ich alles völlig verändern
und diese große Einfluss den die USA
bisher haben denn die Nato hat das darf
alles nicht mehr sein und das hat
natürlich Putin keiner von uns war bei
den Gesprächen dabei wir wissen nicht
wie explizit Putin da erzählt hat wann
er mit dem Krieg loslegt aber er hat das
verstanden als Freifahrtschein weil sie
sich damit gegenseitig ein gemeinsames
Weltbild gemeinsam bewältigt
wahrscheinlich genau und umgekehrt ist
ja zumindest
dokumentiert dass die Chinesen nicht
deutlich widersprochen haben also das
gemacht hat da ist ja keine auffällig
geworden und sagte du du hast ein
gemeinsames Ziel man will im Grunde
genommen das was wir als Weltordnung
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg kennengelernt
haben umdeuten in eine neue Weltordnung
in der eben nicht mehr ich sag mal der
Westen das Sagen hat sondern eben
autoritäre Regime wie Russland und China
ich glaube nur China ist gerade dabei zu
lernen dass die grenzenlose Freundschaft
mit Russland vielleicht doch nicht so
sinnvoll ist weil China studiert sehr
genau studiert sehr genau
was alles in den letzten zwölf Monaten
passiert ist China hat de facto keine
militärische direkt Unterstützung an
Russland gegeben china hat ideologisch
Rückendeckung gegeben bei den Vereinten
Nationen und hat seinen Handel mit
Russland massiv ausgebaut das war
Handelsvolumen Drittel mehr und 190
Milliarden ist das Handelsvolumen
zwischen diesen beiden Staaten aber man
hält sich eigentlich rechts Rück in
dieser Auseinandersetzung warum weil ich
glaube Peking sehr genau sieht was einem
Land angetan werden kann wenn diese
Wirtschaftssanktionen die der Westen ja
gegen Russland beschlossen hat in Sachen
Energie aber in Sachen Hochtechnologie
wenn die auf China auf eine Großmacht
angewendet würden und China ist um ein
Vielfaches auch ein Stück weit abhängig
vom Westen so wie wir von China abhängig
sind das heißt wenn wir es ernst machen
würden und Sanktion verhindern würden
würde
Probleme kommen er hat sowieso
wirtschaftliche Probleme er hat die
Folgen der Pandemie er hat eine
überalterte Gesellschaft also sein Land
könnte sich sehr schnell destabilisieren
wenn der westenähnliche Sanktionen
gleich über die Frage wie stark dieses
als so stark oft beschriebene Land China
wirklich ist sollten wir gleich mal
reden weil es wirklich spannend ist wir
haben gerade über diese Typ Fabrik in
Taiwan gesprochen die so wichtig ist und
auch interessant irgendwie wenn man hört
dass auch zwei deutsche Hersteller
Trumpf und
Trumpf und Zeiss
liefern ganz wichtige Bestandteile für
diese Maschinen man fragt sich immer
warum machen das die Chinesen nicht
selber die können das gar nicht sind die
wirtschaftlich gar nicht so weit
technologisch soweit dass sie solche
Chips selber herstellen können solche
Prozession bisher sind sie tatsächlich
nicht so weit aber sie haben in den
letzten Jahren aufgeholt und die sind
Ding hat die Parole ausgegeben wir
müssen wirklich schnell auch da
unabhängig werden von den anderen und
das macht man unter anderem damit dass
man Experten dass man Forscher dass man
Ingenieure Weg Kauf Luft aus großen
westlichen Firmen ein Beispiel lettes
Halbleiter samiconductors in den USA ein
großes Unternehmen da hat China versucht
sich einzukaufen also in dieses
Unternehmen zu investieren in den USA um
Zugriff natürlich zu den zum Technologie
zu bekommen das hat die US-Regierung
abgewehrt die hat das verboten das war
damals noch unter Barack Obama wurde
diese Investition verboten und daraufhin
hat China einfach zwei der
top-ingenieure der Top Designer für
diese Halbleiter abgeworben die eine
Firma gegründet haben in gonschuh in
China und jetzt eben Konkurrenz sind für
latis samiconductors also man versucht
aufzuholen aber es wird sicherlich noch
einige Jahre dauern bis man soweit ist
und umgekehrt sieht man vielleicht kann
die Regie die Bilder netterweise einmal
zu spielen wie wie unglaublich aggressiv
die Amerikaner ihre eigene
Halbleiterproduktion vorantreiben genau
diese Art von Prozessoren in der Arizona
glaube ich hat hat TS MC die Firma aber
die wir gerade sprechen aus Taiwan
korrigiere mich wenn ich was falsches
sage Elmar die größte Investition
überhaupt in der Geschichte der USA
gemacht 40 Milliarden Dollar von TSMC
sind's 14 Milliarden soweit ich weiß es
gibt aber gleich nebenan ein Werk von
Intel 20 Milliarden Dollar ein weiteres
Werk von Intel enorio 20 Milliarden die
entstehen gerade das sind diese Bilder
für 20 Milliarden eine weitere
Halbleiter verbringen in den USA
Südkorea das heißt man versucht die
Produktion für die wichtigste
Technologie weil wir sie überall
brauchen sei es die Uhr sei es das Handy
sei es das Auto überall steckt sie drin
die versucht man im eigenen Land zu
haben um nicht mehr abhängig zu sein von
China aber auch nicht mehr von Taiwan
und das witzige ist das sogar zeitgleich
in China das gleiche passiert also bei
schichtigen Ding heißt das Main in China
2025 weil auch er möchte nicht diese
Abhängigkeit haben ich meine natürlich
eine Sache aber auch China ist der
technologisch noch auf wenn ich nur Teil
Wahnsinn auch auf den besten angewiesen
und er möchte das genauso nicht haben
weil er seine machtpläne nur
verwirklichen kann wenn China wie er
sagt autark ist so und weil wir die
beiden gerade da sehen gab gerade die
Rede an die Nation von von Joe Biden und
ich sag mal so das war mal klare
Aussprache wir hören mal ganz kurz rein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist Trump 2.0 ja es ist eine
Erkenntnisse genau das absolut und die
Erkenntnis seit 2015 in den USA schon
gewachsen also auch schon vor Trump und
interessanterweise die die damals mit
Joe Biden als er viel zu präsent war in
den Ämtern waren die sind jetzt seine
wichtigsten Berater in Sachen China
Anthony Blinken der Außenminister der
China-Experte in Essen das ist ein
großer das das ist der Vordenker der
Indopazifik Strategie die die
US-Regierung vor einiger Zeit vorgelegt
hat und die besteht aus drei Punkten
erstens sich unabhängig machen
technologisch von China und dafür zu
sorgen dass eben hochtech Technologien
das kommt zweiter Punkt Militär
militärische massiv gegenhalten jüngste
Zeit vor wenigen Wochen der
Verteidigungsminister Osten war auf den
Philippinen und hat doch die Zusage
bekommen dass die US Streitkräfte die
Basen im Norden der Philippinen nutzen
dürfen und das in Japan die Zusage
bekommen auf Okinawa die Mar Raketen
aufstellen aber ist die Insel im Süden
und mit diesem Riegel kann man Taiwan
beschützen das ist also die zweite
Strategie und der dritte Punkt dieser
Strategie ist Verbündete Joe Biden hat
ein Jahr damit zugebracht Verbündete zu
werben rund um den Erdball aber ganz
besonders im innovative er hat ein
wirtschaftsbündnis im Indopazifik vor
einem Jahr oder Dreivierteljahr aus der
Taufe gehoben und versucht im Grunde
genommen
die Staaten dort in der Region zu
überzeugen dass sie sich vor dem
Einfluss Chinas halt gegen diesen
Einfluss wehren müssen
die Chinesen sie als jemand der da so
viele Verbindungen hat sie sind auch mit
deiner chinesischen verheiratet ich
nehme an ihre Kinder sprechen auch
Chinesisch ja mal ganz kurz fragen
stimmt es dass auch die Kinder
amerikanischer Präsidenten und so weiter
dass Obama Kinder sprechen chinesische
herrlich mich das also eine von seinen
Töchtern
und Trumps Enkelin spricht auch
sogar chinesische Lieder vorgesungen das
heißt da ist man sich sehr darüber im
Klaren wo die Reise hingeht auch für die
Zukunft ab ja aber es ist ja
was deswegen macht auch keinen
Unterschied ob Trump oder beiden das ist
ja eine Reaktion auf cheating Ping weil
vorher weiß ich aber China so haben sich
auf die innere Entwicklung konzentriert
auf die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung und
weltpolitisch zurückgehalten und das hat
sich mit cheating Ping völlig verändert
ihm geht es um Vorherrschaft weltweit
und er ist auch entgegen dem es gibt ja
auch noch viele so Unternehmer deutsche
Unternehmer die in China investieren ist
ein das hat damit Kommunismus nicht mehr
zu tun
ist ein knallharter Kommunist wieder
mehr denn je mehr denn je mehr und
vorher vor ihm war so ja pragmatisch nur
und Wirtschaft geht vor allem nein
unterschätzen pink hat die Ideologie
wieder Priorität das wird überall in
Schulen wird jetzt teilweise der
Englischunterricht gestrichen und
ersetzt durch Studium Marxismus und
durch Studium
Gedanken und er hat diesen Gedanken
nicht aufgegeben sondern eher propagiert
ihn wieder weltweit Einfluss
auszuüben früher nannte man das
Weltrevolution er nennt das chinesische
Lösungen anbieten er sagte unsere
Demokratie sich neulich gehört das fand
ich interessant unsere Demokratie eure
Demokratie ist die falsche Demokratie
wir machen hier die richtige Demokratie
fand ich sehr interessant